don't believe everything you read paris
hilton is setting the record straight
when it comes to the viral photo of her
wearing a white tank top that says
stop being poor on monday the dj and
heiress revealed on tick tock that the
message on that signature top was
actually photoshopped
so there's this photo online of me i'm
sure you've seen it
i never wore that shirt this was
completely photoshopped
everyone thinks it's real but that's not
the truth
the photo of paris sporting the top was
taken back in 2005 at a fashion show for
her sister nikki's clothing line
but she reveals the shirt actually had a
different message
writing the caption along with the video
debunking the hashtag stop being pormith
don't believe everything you read this
is what it really said
stop being desperate
don't believe everything you read and
while this revelation was a huge blast
from the past
this isn't the first time paris has made
us reminisce on some of her iconic
moments from the early 2000s
whether it's with her fashion
[Music]
or her famous friendships on monday she
posted a slideshow of some of her
favorite moments with pal britney spears
[Music]
and how can we forget this legendary
moment when paris and pal kim kardashian
recreated some of their looks from the
early 2000s for the skims velour
campaign
that's hot it is
what year is it
and although paris loves a good
throwback it has not stopped her from
continuing to build her fashion
beauty and musical empire paris you have
always been ahead of the curve
what's the next thing what's the next
thing look down the road
open the crystal ball tell us what's
coming up next
i think what's next especially just
in the whole influencer world i think
that the new influencer
is the activist and i'm seeing
a lot of that right now this new
generation that really cares about the
planet
they care about making a difference and
really fighting for causes
and i find that to be just
so commendable and i really applaud them
and i'm impressed by it
and i don't know i just see this whole
shift right now
and it's very impressive paris
you have the brands the fragrances all
this stuff
do you think that now it's time for you
to start creating another
group of ladies that you can you know
the the activist the influencer activist
will you
create the group instead of being the
group
um i have some future projects coming up
so you'll see
and it looks like one of the future
projects she has coming up is
wedding planning in february e.t
confirmed that the mogul is engaged to
boyfriend
carter rheem in september paris told et
that she definitely sees herself having
a family sooner
rather than later does this mean next
phase in your life like maybe marriage
and children and those kinds of things
because
you have been so focused on business
that those things have fallen aside
yes i was never really open to a
relationship because i wasn't ready to
open my heart
just because of what i had been through
so i never
let anyone fully in until now and
now i am just so excited for that next
step
and to get married and have babies and
just finally be hap as happy as i
always wished